[Music] it's been awhile since I've ridden a horse for Andrea has lent us the lovely Annie today we're going to ride one of our beautiful Beach trails the northern Pegasus Bay by law has a few rules you need to be aware of when riding horses along the coastal strip firstly we need to stay on the designated horse trails and give way to people on foot at all times we're more on the beach itself we need to stay in the designated areas for horse riders most of the coastal strip is fine but the ashley recovery estuary is off-limits we also need to stay below the last high tide mark unless we're using an excess trail or avoiding a potentially unsafe situation and finally don't ride through any surf lifesaving areas so it's not too hard just comes down to a bit of common sense and courtesy for others we've all got a part to play in preserving our beaches in estuary find out more at Waimakariri govt T&Z board / beaches [Music]